let's shift to this lady nancy pelosi
you all know nancy pelosi she is the
congresswoman from up there in northern
cali san francisco area she's worth
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
dollars she's been in the government for
how many years i i'm guessing it's got
to be over 40 years at this point
somehow became super super rich she
served as a u.s representative in
california since 1987.
not bad nancy she's 81 years old and she
still wants to run again
she doesn't want to give up power these
people don't want to stop she could be a
scary grandmother right she wouldn't be
like a loving grandmother this is a very
scary woman you wouldn't want to see her
sort of in the morning with no makeup
grandma i want eggs
okay she put out this video
to promote her re-election and take a
look
hello it's nancy
thank you for the opportunity to share
some thoughts with you thank you for
giving me the privilege to represent our
city and our san francisco values in the
congress human rights reproductive
justice lgbtq equality respect for
immigrants and care for each other
when people ask me what are the three
most important issues facing the
congress i always say the same thing our
children our children our children when
you're in the arena you have to be able
to take a punch or throw a punch
for the children our democracy is at
risk because of assaults on the truth
the assault on the us capital and the
state by state assault on voting rights
this election is crucial and that is why
i am running for re-election to congress
and respectfully seek your support
hello i'm nancy pelosi my dentures are
about to fall out of my mouth they've
pulled my skin so tight that my eyes are
actually entering parts of my forehead i
am here to save your children your
children your children your children oh
i think i'm malfunctioning your children
your children also the republicans are
mean and they don't want anyone to vote
ah what is happening to me ah i mean
that is a scary woman lady retire retire
it's time 81
you've got hundreds of millions of
dollars what is going on in your soul if
there is any soul left go
be a grandma you got all that ice cream
in your freezer remember go
spend all the money that you probably
got illegally through insider trading go
do nice things with the children go on
vacation but stop you've ruined
california you've ruined so much of this
country i'm here for the children the
children they're charging
we did a little fun edit take a look
thank you for giving me the privilege to
represent our city and our san francisco
values in the congress human rights
reproductive justice lgbtq equality
respect for immigrants and care for each
other
our safe communities require gun
violence prevention addressing
the plan and supporting law enforcement
with justice and policy i am running for
re-election to congress and respectfully
seek your support
that's some fine work by conor over
there i mean the chili the children that
children that children if she really
cares about the children perhaps you get
critical race theory out of the schools
right perhaps you would make sure that
homeless people haven't completely
overrun san francisco it's disgusting
san francisco is disgusting san
francisco ain't the full house exterior
anymore right it ain't there are drugs
everywhere
needles
store windows broken into you all know
the story about the last time not the
last time previous second to last time
that i was in san francisco i was doing
an event with candace owens we're at
morton's steakhouse we have security in
an escalade and we're obviously on a
nice street where a morton steakhouse
would be and they broke into our car
stole my backpack some homeless guys
running around with one of my jackets
and my nintendo wii and my old notebooks
it's like it's a dump you turn that
place into a dump but we're doing it for
the children the children the children
ah go away lady